welcome everyone I'm Jim Josh Fadel and
this lecture is on the secret life or
lives of pawns so today I'm gonna go
over a game from a tournament which just
concluded the Gibraltar Masters it was
won by aronia and a playoff over a
zillion players which you know I like it
when there's a clear winner when it's a
bunch of quick games and it feels like a
lottery but nevertheless it's a pretty
nice achievement one of the people who
tied with him for first was laQuan lamb
who is a Vietnamese player but it
actually resides in st. Louis who went
to Webster University quite a strong GM
27:37 which puts him in the world's
elite playing an extremely strong
Russian Grandmaster called Daniel dubab
dubab is nearly 2700 young up-and-coming
player so and they're playing for
basically all the marbles in the last
round because I doubt a draw would get
either whom very much and I found this
game to be very interesting from a pawn
structure perspective mainly because
there are so many decisions to make with
their palms but also one of the main
focuses on and what I'd like you to keep
in mind throughout the course of the
lecture is how pawns determine where
your pieces should be because I think
that's something that people forget a
lot they focus purely on the ponds which
is all well and good but you also have
to figure out well if my pawns are here
that usually means my peat your pieces
should be in certain positions and
that's a theme that comes up throughout
this game and probably what I want to
focus on most but of course I go off on
tangents and say random things so you
never know efore c5 not gonna announce
every move but we have a rosa limo g6
and now Knight c3 to my knowledge this
is not really the most common move most
people here either play a setup where
they take and play h3 something like
this which is its own usually they you
actually go against the rules and take
away from the center B takes is a move
but the idea of this is that you open up
your bishop very common and in Lopez
very common here and white usually even
plays this to prevent this and okay this
is a kind of a main type of system a lot
of the times they even play it before
you even castle and then it gives you
the option of castling queenside
sometimes but okay I digress rook e1 is
a very common option here and then but
it allows Knight f6 Knight e5 you don't
have to play Knight e5 of course but you
can play Knight c3 here 97 life kind of
goes on but white opted for 93 so the
main purpose as far as I can tell is
that now Knight f6 you have this e5
option and while you can still do this
you have to at least endure a slightly
off Knight so for example I can play h3
at some point kick it back to h6 maybe
not the end of the world but sometimes
this night can be rather annoying to
have to deal with that so I don't know I
mean it's it's just another way to play
kind of and also it's very possible
white could play rook e1 and 2 and it's
pretty similar to main lines but okay
black played a 5 so already this is a
notable pawn structure decision right so
whenever you play a move like a 5 what
do you have to consider exactly for now
now this is just a hole and it's gonna
be a hole for awhile so when you play e5
you have to make sure that the weakness
of d5 isn't too severe for example if
there were no light squared Bishop sand
you ended up with this a knight here
against the bishop here you could almost
resign it's that bad obviously I'm not
advocating resignation in a position
like this but I would say that it's bad
enough you that it usually just lost
positionally because this Knight is just
so much better but with
all the pieces on the board that's not
really the case and you guys probably
know from experience playing lots of
openings this is a weakness that's
created all the time but I would say
that if you do create this weakness you
need to get something for it you don't
just create it for nothing so what is
black get for the weakens d5 square very
good control over d4 that's about as
good control over d4 as a person can
dream of
so if white had any hopes of playing d4
well they're gonna have to find another
idea
note how the Knights here also so
there's no c3 d4 ideas either sometimes
that doesn't matter but something I
would note you also prevent a5 pushes
and you create a square on e7 for your
knight which i think is rather
harmonious actually this is a very
common setup and usually if you have
pawn d6 and pieces like this you want
your night to go to e7 so it allows you
that bad option in any case e5 is a very
common move so I know it's kind of early
in the opening but I like to kind of
focus on you know even from the very
beginning of the game where you put your
pawns dictates where you put your pieces
97 so we come to this position now even
early as early as this phase even as
early as this point white already has a
misplaced piece I would like you guys to
find it and I'm not including like the
rook on a1 yes the rook on a one could
be improved but that's something that we
all have to live with it's a cross we
have to bear what developed piece of
whites is not placed correctly
incidentally I'm not totally positive
you even would take with the knight if
you take with the be pawn and play d6
your structure is really nice
you control the d5 square that's
certainly not a weakness anymore but I
just like the night here in general I
think it's out of the way but yeah this
piece is wrong now because taking the
knight you're not interested in that
what's the weakness that black has what
Square d5
so because of where the pawns are
because of how both sides set up it's
clear that this is now misplaced
so white fixes it so black plays here
white plays a3 black plays these things
so you have this position what to do
don't all answer at once I'm just
kidding it's not an easy position is it
seems like all your pieces are decent
but what do you do you can bring the
bishop out to g5 but I play h6 that
doesn't really help you right you could
play Bishop III or Bishop d2 and
technically you're developing a piece
you can congratulate yourself but the
problem with this is that is the bishop
really doing anything on e3 or d2 very
possible but then I'm gonna ask why is
your bishop on e3 I'm gonna play 94 and
then your bishop doesn't really look
that good to me
but laQuan managed to find a very active
move that puts Brad black at least
forces black to make choices immediately
let me just give you an example if white
played a move like h3 ah he threw this
in sorry I thought this was the key
moments but he threw in the move h3 to
avoid Bishop g4 that was my bad
but h6 we come to the same type of thing
what does black want to play by the way
possibly some positions maybe even
Bishop e6 the doubled pawns look a
little weird but maybe not so easy to
take advantage the white needs a way to
create activity the general rule is even
if a game is sort of closed if you don't
have a plan to create activity or
improve your pieces your opponent
probably does so you need something to
do and I can tell you that laQuan
probably saw this position it was like
you know what blacks idea is common
Black's gonna play King h7 f5 on me
maybe I need to do something right now
so what idea comes to mind
Nate H for Nate H - that's possible
I wouldn't say your night looks all that
nice here but ok let's say I play I
don't know Kingston Bishop e6 was also
worth considering here but F for so
you're improving your pawn everything
makes sense I don't know I might be able
to play off five
you might experience some problems here
right because your night is just really
not good and you don't always have time
to get back because this hangs I don't
know I would be a little uncomfortable
here to be honest he found a different
idea and I hope I'm right this time
because if I get the wrong move again
it'll be super embarrassing g4o who
wants to tell me why this move is a form
of suicide yes the this is not a happy
king right here now after king h7 f5 is
about a million times stronger please
guys don't don't play move like g4 save
a life so but okay let go and choose a
different path this is a very very
common break in these positions and it's
hard for people to imagine because they
see this weakness right but I can tell
you that experienced players know this
is nuts not a big deal the square can be
weak till the end of time but if you
can't do anything if you can't open up a
part of the board if you can't try to
use something else this square alone is
not going to do anything for you if
black plays King h7 and lots of
checkmating attack you're not going to
get a prize because you have d5 and in
fact the fact that the center is so
closed actually hurts you so you often
need to create sect more weaknesses you
need to force black to make different
decisions so a move like b4 already
poses a question to black are you
worried about b5 are you worried about
takes can you take my pawn I can tell
you from experience you'll very rarely
find a GM who takes this pawn however
that does not mean other players do not
or that people never take obviously
taking if it wins upon it wins upon but
almost always in this kind of position
you will encounter problems if you take
a pawn like this I actually have had a
student around 2300 who always wants to
take this pawn I always have to say no
don't do it
but let's see because taking this pawn
definitely looks logical now so what's
the problem you take back I assume
Knight takes how do you follow up and
this is usually the play that this pawn
now is a huge weakness and look at these
bishops all of a sudden they look pretty
nasty right so black were to just move
back and you play here serious problems
right if you win the pawn back after
sacrificing this almost always you have
a huge advantage because these pawns
aren't really going anywhere and look at
these powerful pieces now you see the
problem the question is can black do
anything about it there's only one real
try I think for black to to really try
to hold on to this pawn yeah play the
other ninety six and here I think I
found a very very nice move for white so
I looked at rook b1 but it wasn't super
convincing even Knight a6 to c5 is
possible I looked at ninety five but it
seemed like you were letting black off
too easy
but there's one piece of whites that is
not quite in this Queen side play and
you want to get it into play
which piece of whites is clearly wrong
one of the pieces that's out that's out
you're definitely right that if you say
this rook is not well placed the problem
is it takes way too long to get in the
game time is a factor Queen I don't know
queen bee one looks a little weird I
don't trust it Plus remember this is
blacks idea anyway indeed where would
this Knight like to go wrong side of the
board wrong side of the board you want
to be here also this hangs the night so
be careful so remember the pawn
structure control that dictates where
your pieces go
what's blacks weakness indeed so where
should this Knight be headed yep so for
example if black plays a five you play
Knight b5 and c3 is gonna be a world of
hurt you guys can see that right yeah
like seriously seriously hurt
yeah you're gonna know bandage is big
enough after c3 so a six is the logical
course of action and it's weird but you
can't really take advantage of this
Knight and b5 is gonna come in a lot of
positions also but now you play rook be
one Queen has to come out to a5 and now
believe it or not you play very simply
you take and then what move do you think
you play is wait mmm better where does
this Knight want to be so this should be
three I can play b5 or Bishop e6 I have
a move remember don't give me time I
don't know about Bishop e6 by the way
that's probably bad but b5
you don't have to be that nuts just go
here and the Queen has to go back
probably right this is amazingly
unpleasant remember what I told you
about this bishop against the knight
being almost dead
you might end up there and although
you're down upon this guy is pretty bad
wouldn't you say after a move like rook
b8 you can even shove the rook in play
queen bee one Queen out rook here I
don't know about you but I would not
want to be black what do you guys think
alright so you see it I mean there's
almost always something but a lot of it
involves being a little subtle if you
just play rook be one Queen a5 at first
you may not have had anything if you
tried to take the knight too soon you
just fizzle out but you play ninety to
first wait to see what black does and
you can see how your your position just
builds itself your pieces just improve
themselves so this kind of pawn sack
when you have a structure like this this
kind of pawn sack happens all the time
and the reason why is because this
structure is really annoying to face if
you don't have a break right if you
don't break down the structure you're
basically just getting clamped in the
center so you need a way to break it
down but black was like well what's the
big deal black plays King h7 he's like I
don't care about taking on c5 it's no
big deal
no skin off my back incidentally another
advantage of b4 is that moves like
Bishop e6 are really discouraged now
because you take take these pawns with a
helper on d6 don't look so bad when
they're like this no never ever do this
this just looks awful I I remember even
the very precise game where I learned
not to do this it was in Vermont I think
it was like early 2000s against
Ukrainian I am and he tortured me for a
long time with these pawns and I hated
the game so much I never allowed him
again so sometimes wisdom is born from
pain they case
King age 7 dubov I'm sure already knows
he's almost 2700 he's probably learned
that lesson before so white ticks so
here's kind of my question for you
what did white exactly accomplish I
can't really see too well so you can
just say something ah yep V file is
definitely something you can use loosen
the center a little bit right it's a
little bit looser and that's kind of
what you're playing for you've loosened
black up just that touch but it's not
gonna mean anything if you don't follow
it up correctly because black still
looks relatively solid I can play b6
you've actually opened up my queen but
you'll see that a lot of if you're again
if you're watching GM's play this kind
of structure you'll see after b4 they
usually just allow you to capture
because even though this is a slight
accomplishment it's not that big of a
deal in a lot of positions I still think
it was right right of white to do it
because if you don't I think you have
very little counter play but it's still
you know an upward task but at least you
have a B file at least you have ways to
book pressure so I played rugby once
begin B file black played b6 so now what
remember you got to create counter plane
though I would mention that f5 is a
little bit less effective
when the center is more open because
then options like takes are a little bit
less comfy right without a pawn here
black either
has to take with a piece and give up
this square or take with a pawn and then
the King's open see that so that's one
of the other advantages of taking I
forgot to mention that f5 now is not
unplayable but much riskier and again
sometimes that's all it's about like you
can't necessarily prevent every move but
you can at least make your opponent
think twice make them take a risk in
order to try to do something but okay
we're just talking to improving moves
howcome way to improve here you take
advantage of b6 a little bit with this
move
a4 is coming does anyone know what this
pawn is called by the way this loneguy
first of all is this pawn a strength or
a weakness
I actually think they're correct that
it's usually a strength in this
structure if this pawn weren't here
you'd be absolutely right it's a
weakness if this palm were here for
example I would kind of hate White's
position if this power on a 5 then
Yahtzee weakness this pawn yeah why why
what's gonna attack it
that's not attacking this it could be
weak in positions with the pollen a4
with a5 it could be weak but this is
also a weakness right but I would say
that this pawn is usually a strength
more than a weakness because of the Ray
it's a ray is what it's called you just
shoot the pawn up the board it plays a5
and then black has to make structural
sacrifices they either play this then
you have the ugly as pawns ever or you
allow takes and create a weakness so in
this kind of structure this isolated
pawn so to speak is actually a strength
and this is what I mean by you can't go
by hard and fast rules just because
technically this is an isolated pawn
does not mean it's a weakness in this
position against this structure this is
an annoyance this is a strength so it's
important to realize that because a lot
of people be like wait take sticks I
have an isolated pawn why am i doing
this well there's a very good reason
however this pawn is not a strength at
all if it can never play a5 right this
pawn can't head to a5 it's just I mean
I'm not even gonna say it's a weakness
but it's just sitting there just
chilling out which is okay sometimes
that's all pawns can do but you'd need
to trade a couple pieces in order to get
this guy up here right so how do you
start
black plays here
white trades I thought white might try a
knight Knight III but it's a little
awkward I don't know I don't mind what
he did exactly
so of course tactic to work out if you
take this bishop I take the knight I
have a few too many pieces well one too
many piece but that's enough if you take
with the knight of course I make your
pawns really ugly and then I have to
remember my game and cry so of course
black played Queen takes e7 and how does
white continue now and once again you're
using the pawn structure to determine
your course of action with your pieces
what can you do to improve a piece now
if you just take what do you think of
your position
not horrible right but what are you
doing I control the center really well
you have to watch out for c4 by the way
maybe you can maneuver this Knight but
I'm still not convinced you're actually
accomplishing a whole lot so white tries
to be a little sneakier
so note how with a pawn here this kind
of moved tends not to be a big deal
because so what you know but now you
have a continuation which is rather
annoying c4 but guys you're creating a
weak upon what are you doing so this is
kind of my point if you just take the
pawn structure by itself this pawns
horrible right however why is this pawn
not a weakness at all because this is
blocked and it's blocked forever you're
never ever moving this guy those are the
rules I don't care if it's attacked by a
pawn I'm just kidding but basically this
guy is never ever moving so if you want
to take this bishop I put up on there
and why is it significant that there's
no pawn on d6 apart from the fact the
Queen's there I always like to avoid
missteps why does it matter that there's
no pawn here indeed so now no matter how
you take this you have to create not
only a not only get give me a pawn
that's taken away squares from your
pieces that's a pass pawn so you see how
again this structure by itself not a
good structure because there's a piece
there it changes the whole evaluation of
the position so I'm not saying why it's
killing here honestly I don't even know
who's better but White's course of
action regardless of the evaluation is a
logical one right and the whole but the
whole point is that you're not
considering the pawn structure by
yourself but in but you're taking pieces
into account and your P and your pawns
are determining where your pieces go and
in some case by severe so the only
reason you're playing pawn here is
because this is a bishop here if there
weren't a bishop here this move would be
ridiculous and you would get laughed at
and it'll be not fun
in any case black plays rook b8 no one
likes having a pinned peace even gm's so
here white plays this move I thought
Bishop d2 was kind of more to the point
but okay he he wants to hit the e5 pawn
because now by the way I should mention
you
might take this night if it means taking
this pawn for free I should mention
there's it's not like you never move the
bishop regardless but but okay black
plays back you don't want to take the
bishop now the knight now I would say
the exception though you might consider
taking this Knight if then a knight can
land here put another piece but okay
white plays Bishop C 397 so yeah Queen
d2 I actually didn't like I actually
think the Queen's kind of weird here I
don't know I might have just played rook
e1 so the idea is that now f5 is kind of
discouraged but I can play kind of like
they did in the game but the Queen here
I think is actually well placed for that
and I'll show you why that is but the
point is you put a cook here you kind of
improve a piece eventually a4 a5 is
gonna come but you don't have to rush
right that idea is not going anywhere
you just have to make sure that blacks
b5 move is not too annoying but honestly
I'm not so sure that this is gonna work
out all that amazingly should probably
figure out why though why is this move
not so great I think the point is that
now you can play Queen d2 and prevent b4
and again this pawn is actually a little
loose in some of these lines even a move
like Queen B 2 can be considered not
immediately of course but at some point
because this pawn is gonna be weak
I don't know b5 is a risky move because
this is kind of the side of the board
that white wants to open right
not to mention that actually you might
just take this pawn because even though
you give up this Bishop there's now this
weakness as well so black can defend
that pawn but then you put upon on a 4
and this pawns against this pawn this is
a known structure that's very dangerous
so even though you have the two bishops
I don't know I would say that this is
risky for black these pawns in the
endgame are just monsters okay but again
a lot of questions consider I'm guessing
that he played Queen d2 though against
that that could be because I was I just
thought it was a mysterious move but
sometimes ideas just kind of occur to me
so black played what I thought was a
very nice idea black plays g5 not here
so what is blacks goal and it's not a
very deep one what is black trying to do
and I don't have four and basically just
trying to checkmate
so the second the pawn lands here the
game changes entirely how does it change
well let's start with what idea of
blacks is probably going to be less
effective with a pawn on g5 usually now
there's a bishop on d5 which actually
works against you in the f5 positions
but in general when you play off five
you do not want to take with a piece so
f5 ideas tend to be a little bit less
good now however you're trying to put a
knight an f4 you're trying to go after
White's King which means that white has
to set up some kind of barrier white has
to make it so it's not so easy for black
to just swoop in and try to give
checkmate does King H to help you
g3 is gonna be a little tricky not to
mention if the King here might feel a
little uncomfortable lined up with this
queen all of a sudden f5 is more
tempting isn't it right because if you
play here I might have this move now
because if you take check and whoopsies
right so if and if my pawn lands here by
the way you're just gonna not be very
happy just so you know then you're
playing kind of an awful Kings inium and
by the way almost all close pawn
structures like this when the pawn lens
on f4 it's some kind of Kings Indian it
can be an awful kings in it can be an
amazing Kings ideon for a muz
perspective I don't know but the idea is
that almost always when the pawn gets
here it means that white better have
really good play I would say though that
you have to be careful of queen bee too
but as long as 96 is available shouldn't
be a big deal okay white played rook e1
so this also discourages f5 but alright
Black's idea was not f5 anyway Knight g6
so what now how do you try to keep black
at bay there's a common misconception I
think about moves like g4 whenever you
play moves on your opponent's side of
the board usually you're speeding them
up not slowing them down now I'm not
saying g4 is completely nonsensical if
you can completely lock up the game it's
a success but after Knight f4 you better
have an answer to Queen g6 h5 because
it's coming
I mean well Queen g6 depends upon yeah I
guess Queen g6 this hangs so maybe you
have to be more careful than that but
even if black plays a move like Bishop
f6 and h5 it just first of all you have
to defend this pawn and this looks
really risky doesn't begin to cover how
I feel about this move it's something
looks off right like you you're just
asking to get sacked on and have a
brilliancy price dropped on your face
it's all I can tell you so g4 you have
to be very careful with this kind of
move
and it's one of those moves you'd rather
not play unless you have everything
under control
so I'm not saying for forget about this
move entirely but be very cautious with
moves like g4 hmm queen bee - but the
problem is this you're just preventing
it for one move right I defend the pawn
and then you're not preventing it
anymore yeah you may not even go to g4
but the idea is that the knight here
kind of keeps these pawns from rolling
down your face now and this is something
like it's it's never fun to have a
knight here but if you've played the
white side of King's Indian a few times
you know that sometimes you got to
sometimes if there are pawns just
getting thrown at you you need a piece
to just stand there and go like this
just say look don't hurt me too bad I'm
gonna hold you up and what you're
claiming is that eventually you're gonna
crash through on the Queen side if you
give me enough time I'm gonna beat you
in the Queen side but until then I'm
just gonna hold you off keep you at
arm's length so sometimes moves like net
h2 are kind of necessary so black plays
metaphor I'd be kind of scared here as
white but lik Cuong is a brave fellow he
doesn't care so he plays rook e3 trying
to keep everything hot how long - black
plays h5 so queen d1 so Quinn do you
want this two things first of all it
kind of reminds black that this pawn
could hang trying to tempt black into h4
why of course would that be a poor move
mm-hmm
locks up the punch you never want to
lock up the pawns er you're attacking
almost always and it also keeps an eye
on the other side of the board what move
might you want to play indeed
so I think that Queen d2 is a poor move
mostly because it just really was a
waste of time in those positions and I
could be he was also worried about b5
but the more I look at b5 the more I
just dislike it cuz really that's white
side that's not your side so if you try
to play with b5 probably something Bad's
gonna happen but now he's not worried
about b5 at all cuz here I'm just happy
I'm like yes please let's open every lie
possible because then these moves look
ridiculous right you can't even take
this bishop so easily because this pawn
hangs with check right so I'm very happy
to see b5 the second you start launching
you want to keep open board is usually
not a bad thing so black of course plays
queen g6 and now white plays kind of a
funny move I don't know if this is a
good move or not my instincts tell me
this move shant shouldn't be good but
that's not an argument I'm sure if I
went up to let Kwan was like dude my
instincts are telling you not to play
this you'd be like all right man but the
idea is it's just the idea is very
simple you wants to discourage this g4
push he wants to make it as hard for
black as possible but I think the rook
could end up kind of weird here and I'm
not convinced g4 was even that playable
I can take it play rook g3 after g4 I
don't think it's such a big deal just
yet so I don't know if I would have
played this but it makes sense he's
trying to put up stop to these pawns and
he's also trying to provoke h4 and we're
all happy to see H floor right so black
played f6 white played Bishop d2 so
again he's just trying to put a little
pressure once this pawn lands here the
bishops silly here right so he's always
looking to improve his pieces visual h6
so blacks building sometimes you get to
a point where your defensive pieces are
as good as they're gonna be right those
are the moments you want to look for you
know what now is the time to play on the
other side of the board because let's
face it I mean how else is why can a
defend against all these guys there's no
way right I would say one of the things
that separates like the very strongest
players from players who aren't quite as
good is that they know which side when
to switch gears if you just play only
defensive moves probably you're gonna
lose because there's only so good your
defenders can get if you play only
offensive moves probably you're gonna
get checkmated so you have to find the
proper balance once you have the main
threats taken care of and you can't
really improve your defenders that's
usually the time you know what I'm gonna
play on the other side and by the way
playing on the Queen side
help defend your king can you guys tell
me why that might be indeed black son
then has to react black might have
weaknesses over here so I can't move
sometimes if you open up this side and a
rook gets in a rook on the seventh could
certainly interrupt blacks attack right
so playing on the opposite side of the
board can even help you against the
attack but also it comes down to you
want to have some fun too right so let's
go black played Queen back to eight so
blacks idea here is that now if you play
five and I play b5 you have kind of a
problem because I've locked this down a
little bit so trying to trying to do
anything over here is gonna be tricky
and now I'm threatening b4 keep in mind
with the pollen a three before was not
an issue right so he was kind of
tempting but okay white please rook a
one White's not in a hurry and black
plays a5 I'm gonna tell you right now
before ever in this structure you play
moving a five take a second thing I'm
not gonna say it's always a bad move or
then it's always a bad decision but I'd
say one of the most common pawn
structure decisions I ever see made is
this move a file I will tell you it
tends to be made more often by younger
players
notice how do Bob is playing the move a
five he's a very very young player
obviously extremely strong I'm not
saying anything about lead a I'm sure he
knows this concept but I can just tell
you that even when it's correct you'll
see experienced GM's almost never play
this move and the reason why is they
just know in the long term this guy
being weak tends not to be as important
as that guy being weak once the if you
trade these pawns for example who has
the weak pawn who has the better
structure it's white right this pawn is
often a weakness more than a strength
and it means that White's achieved their
goal they weaken this pawn so almost
always it's better to allow a5 than to
prevent it with a five
our exceptions I'm never gonna say it's
a hundred percent I would say it's maybe
70/30 but I would say that if you're
going to play a five take a second think
never just play it because more often
than not that's gonna be your pawn move
which was an error and I'm telling you
this is one of the true pawn secrets I
can reveal to you before you play if I
take that second thing I'm not saying
don't play it but I'm saying think about
it because I think if dubov played rook
d8 for example preparing for openings
here and b5 I think he actually I would
probably rather be black I don't like
having my pieces like this maybe you're
arguing I'm elitist or something but
somehow somehow this doesn't make me
happy
so honestly after b5 I don't know I'd
might rather be black still complicated
I'm not saying the game is simple but
the second I see this move I know that
in the long term you have to be very
careful and you're gonna see what I mean
because a certain in the game that
didn't go in blacks favor you're gonna
see how awful this move can be so Knight
was a five indeed and I'm telling you
most older experienced GM's you will
very rarely see this move this is just
something I've noticed wait I even had a
game I remember it was the US
Championship I was watching with Alex
golden who is you know I worked with as
a trainer was a very experienced GM I
think he's almost 50 now and we were
watching a game of Ray Robson's
obviously ray is extremely strong
stronger than me right it was an end
game where he was defending the NCI
source erawan and he was thinking about
the movie v and I was looking at it but
I was kind of leaning against it ray by
the way played it very fast this exact
move in a similar structure I was
thinking about it and I was like it's
interesting maybe but I it may not be
necessary I'd rather not play it and
golden was like ah a five fish move and
I think that really highlights the
difference in experience it doesn't mean
he's always gonna be right but it means
that experienced GM's are far less
likely to play this move so
be very careful yep oh I would say no no
I'd say almost never do you take because
if you take then you have weak to
weaknesses I'd rather have one than two
but the point is this you give the
weakness anyway and it doesn't take as
an extra move the thing with a five
though is it opens up the a file so it's
an extra thing although in this
particular case there's b5 as a move so
they're all different again like you
can't do a hundred percent but I'm just
saying like if you take that extra think
if you're a little bit more reluctant I
think it helps you and I can tell you
that these young players like dubov and
like Robson the more they look at them
the more reluctant they become as they
get more experienced so it doesn't mean
you never play it I think that's am also
a mistake but you want to be reluctant
you want it to be difficult so black
play broke the egg so here I actually
thought that white could sack up on with
93 takes Knight f5 and I thought that if
you ever given us Bishop for this night
you're just gonna be very unhappy with
your life but okay he didn't want to
sack anything
he played rook a3 again probably
wouldn't be I don't know III wanted to
just play a 93 but whatever Bishop c8 93
rook d6 rook f3 so here I'm trying to
remember here so rook f3 he wants to
play Knight a5 but he's worried about
you know some kind of cap tax here and
takes here so he's trying to yeah this
is actually a very tricky move because
if you play Knight f5 immediately
your rooks hanging but when you move it
you're now threatening that f5 because
after takes your rook is no longer
hanging these guys are clever aren't
they
but yeah it's it's kind of a very common
sort of GM trick but okay this should be
7g for your move what is the difference
between G for now and G for previously
and I should mention that this was
another point of rook F 3 because that
now I think this is actually an
excellent move it doesn't look that
different but the key difference is that
now white is an improved piece right
this Knight is here ready to hop into f5
ready to control this pawn so basically
what White's saying is that now when I
play g4 you're going to be completely
controlled and you're not gonna be able
to sack here this rook may look strange
but it's actually ok place because it's
defending this pawn yeah so I
incidentally just so you know I did lied
to you before Knight f5 here I thought
that this was all clever but the problem
is that now this rook is just trapped
just thought I'd let you know so don't
listen to me too closely yeah so g4 was
his main idea black plays Rock h8 rubgy
yeah again I think Matta 5 immediately
was playable but he played rope cheese
their first bishop back
Knight a5 there's no choice but to take
right this is why I hate this move all
of a sudden black would wave yeah so at
least you have the hope of not just
giving up all the light squares in the
universe and this is kind of the problem
when you have a pawn here if you get a
position like this you're you're
basically signing up to sit for the rest
of the game you will not get to play a
single active move because with this
pawn here Y can take all the time in the
world now you might argue that well I
don't want to open up the board anyway
but when
play this move your basically you have a
weakness here and you have no Connor
plate forever and it's one of those
threes ins y again the more experienced
players are the more reluctant they are
to play a move like this because it just
it defines the pawn structure completely
and makes it so that you just don't have
any form of counter play and believe me
in this position you want some counter
play so black played here now there's no
point because you're not really gonna do
anything on the Kings side anyway rook
III Queen h5 I'm not objecting to an
endgame roof b3 are you guys starting to
see what I mean about blacks position
this guy is just the weakness right is
this a weakness now you could argue that
black made some mistakes to get here and
I'd say you'd be right but when you have
to be this cautious it often means that
you may be made a weakness you shouldn't
have made but okay there should be seven
so blacks claim is just that you're not
gonna be able to break through I'm gonna
put a bishop here and how are you gonna
get in so electron was like let me show
you
rook e1 King G - so what's he trying
with King G - where is he headed
note how he's not really in a rush and
guess what he doesn't have to be there's
no kind of play right so in this
position I think blacc blundered blacks
should probably play Knight f4 takes
takes but White has a very strong idea
here you could have taken with the Jeep
off but then h4 is just the free pawn
basically and you can play rook G 1 2 G
H 5 g6
but what is y2 here keep in mind that
even as as pretty as your position may
look if you can't break through being
pretty doesn't count for anything well
it counts for a little depends on the
type of tournament you're playing but
for the most part you need something
concrete you need a way to break through
so how do you break through here how
many breaks do you have ok so how do you
play 45 you can and then what yeah but
why do you feel like you have to be
fancy about it just be a plebeian that's
fine rookie 1 you just can't stop it
exactly and once you get on e5 you bring
your rook in should be nice and toasty
all right
but that plate here instead he's still
saying look I got you covered you don't
have a breakthrough perhaps you don't
have to quite sack a piece to get what
you want though
get rid of your weak pawn
I'm calling it week because we know it's
not with the bishop here right but do
you for and you see how blacks whole
opera kind of falls apart here
so if takes c5 takes takes this is it
just pretty brutal because now if you
play here probably I have lots of ways
to do this actually the simplest is
probably just taking and creating a
passer no I mean the two bishops are
gonna kind of wreck you here but okay
yeah maybe there was even something
better I'm not sure but this looks
pretty good in any case no doubt you
have more options when you're not down
apiece always a plus
so black took here and now what keep
your bishops so now taking here is
pretty much illegal because I take the
knight for free right takes here I
thought maybe sack in exchange was it
okay try but even here this is pretty
much over
cuz rook c6 is a problematic move next
and you have to move the knight because
this is still a threat so you have to go
here then here and you don't get to keep
your connected passers there's more the
point unless you want to trade rooks
which will have problems but okay I
thought maybe was a better practical try
black just played back which is actually
interesting so now what yeah this is the
kind of thing which you want to consider
always like right away because it's like
think about it with your rooks just
sitting here if these rooks can't get in
they're just they're just sitting there
they're waiting at the drawbridge
forever right
you got to crash through eventually so
yeah
now you're threatening Bishop g5 you're
threatening pawn takes up six I don't
know about you but looks kind of
overwhelming not to mention being down
in exchange when you have these two
monster bishops is not such a bad thing
but notice what he chosen the game did
not give up any of his monstrous pieces
right he kept them all so black played
Knight f4 check take take take so here
he could have been he would got a little
lazy I think that like this would have
just ended the game I mean okay you can
take this bishop but I don't think
that's gonna help your cards too much
these pawns are a little strong but okay
he did it kind of the simpler way he
just took which is fine of course d3
came back and soon enough it was just
over he'd resigned here because he's
gonna have to these pawns roll you win
the rook and you have a zillion pawns so
anyway it was kind of an interesting an
interesting battle notice that really
you defied a lot of pawn structure norms
you created weaknesses to kind of assist
your pieces your pieces went where the
pawn said they should go notice how when
these pawns are ripping down the board
you had to put a piece on an ugly square
but that's where the pawn said the piece
had to go otherwise you would have just
run into a nasty attack and then notice
how this a5 move it looked kind of
harmless at first right how bad would
this move at the end just awful right it
allowed white to just crash through
completely so be very very careful about
any move I would say that completely
locks the pawn structure is the move you
got to be careful of because usually you
can't take that back once you've played
a5 you can't be like adjust later in the
game unless you're really sneaky so just
the kind of thing you have to be careful
with but again kind of not a perfect
game by any means but I thought it was
really nice the way he not only the way
he took advantage of this but the way he
kind of regrouped from in my opinion in
a tough position brought his pieces back
and then eventually crashed through with
some nice pawn breaks like the d4 pawn
break is kind of a classic and just very
nice
[Music]